it was disconcerting to be validated for
something that I believed 22 years ago
and that I got a lot of other people to
believe 22 years ago including Doubleday
to the tune of two million dollars in
Disney to the tune of a million and new
line to the tune of a million plus and
so on and then it didn't happen and
suddenly all these years later it
happens and people go you must feel good
to be corroborated and I said yes I do
but the truth is it taught me the most
important lesson of all which I wrote
into it as they called the waiting room
if I have been waiting for the Meg to
happen or for any movie that I started
20 years ago to happen I probably would
be miserable if not suicidal but what
you do in the waiting room is you do
something else that's how you manage
your time when you're waiting for
something that can be annoying and a
burden and the what you have to do is
other things so what I did was 50 other
things as a result thirty movies have
happened and hundreds of books and a new
publishing company and lots of other
things and yes it's satisfying to see
that the world endorses what Steve Elton
and I believed in 22 years ago that this
was you know a hugely popular subject
for a story and all the way along brave
people especially Bill Avery who brought
it home and Lorenzo de Bona Ventura
right said every other producers they
made it happen too but it just I guess
what it shows among other things is that
don't waste time hoping for something to
happen do your work and then put it out
in the world and let the world take care
of it that's one thing and then part of
it is to trust your the work that
happened when you know when you create
this baby the meg in this case if it's a
good baby
you
we'll survive and it will show us
muscles when the time comes
maybe it's been in hiding for all these
years but suddenly it comes out and
everybody knows it that's great but what
that tells the artist I think is to
focus on what's at hand what's in your
workshop right now and do it well
and then don't worry about things you
can't control
focus on what you can control and I
guess that's my main feeling about it is
that we did a lot of work on the Meg at
the beginning we created its shape and
finally came out and it did great and my
surprise no I'm pleased but I'm not
surprised because I always believed it
but I am so glad I didn't hang my own
personal psychology on it because if I
had done that I had been you know locked
up I know it's like like like myself
Steve went on to write eight more books
on different subjects to and built
another career around his talent and
he'll continue doing that he's learned
that less than two that was
disappointing that it didn't come out
back then well it felt like it at the
time that in retrospect things are meant
to be and I always say to writers that I
manage that every project has its own
clock and the only problem is you can't
see the clock so what you do is you put
in the works the best you can and and
you screw the screws right you know the
screws on the cover and send it out into
the world and wish it well and turn to
your next project which hopefully you've
done before you finish this what project
and that's what that's what the Creator
does they keep working on new projects
so this role didn't are not perfectly
God creates another world
maybe it's better
what he was doing was creating something
that no one else could create and he
told me that he spent he wrote every day
for ten years before he wrote a single
line a single word that was uniquely his
and then one day he sat down and he
wrote the words the lake and he wrote a
short story based on the time when he
was a little boy when he was eight years
old he and a little girl friend who was
seven when swimming in Lake Michigan and
he came out and she never did she
drowned and it was a story of had her
coming back as a ghost and he told me
that when he finished this story
tears were streaming down his face and
he knew he had written something that no
one else could have written it came
specifically from his experience and his
soul and he said it took a and it took
another two years of writing every day
before he could write something again
that was uniquely his and they got to
where he could do it again and again and
again and he became Ray Bradbury because
he was determined to do that and so I
thought that was a great lesson to say
okay what are you creating what can you
create that isn't something that's just
an imitation of what others are doing
but that's unique to you that no one
else could have created that you create
something fresh in the world that's
truthful and meaningful and and then you
know you've done something worth doing
so that's that's been a great
inspiration to me
I love Meijin I think he's the best
agent in the world I'm repping that
repped at WME there was another agent
WME who I think is the second best agent
in the role then her name is Audra NAT
Alba Getty and she said something once
that I think is so important for writers
to hear she said that some writers get
it and some writers don't get it and the
writers who get it are all working and
the writers who don't get it
most of them aren't working and so as an
agent she just wants to work with
writers who get it and this is what it
is a lot of writers think that you know
to write a script that changed your life
to write a script that gets you your
first job or to get really Scott to hire
you or to get a whatever it is
you're aspiring to you have a career
you're trying to take it to the next
level they think it's about writing that
having the right script at the right
time at the right place that's not it
and that's a mistake that surrenders all
control and power to the universe the
reality is your job is to think in six
script cycles and you have to be writing
the right kinds of scripts pitch perfect
authentic we talked about that earlier
and assuming you trained yourself not to
build to do that you need to write six
of those every two years and the reason
is if you write six of these pitch
perfect authentic scripts one of them is
going to go out to the marketplace and
just fizzle and you'll never know why
and then two or three of them will go
out and they'll start to get some
traction but then something will happen
in Darrell it and then it'll be one or
two that's absolutely going to happen
you have the director attached you have
the stars there's a bidding war there's
no way it's not gonna happen and
something at the very last second it's
gonna derail it and one of the six will
actually go the distance and sell or
it'll be that script that gets you the
next three or four years of getting
staffs on show there'll be one of those
six scripts that will just catch
lightning in a bottle one of those sex
you don't know which one it'll be so if
you're not working right now you ought
to be writing three or four of these
scripts a year because you're thinking
and six script cycles so any one script
goes out and ultimately doesn't do what
you need to do you don't feel like a
victim that's one of six
this is the key if you are working you
have two jobs now you have your day job
and your weekend night job so if your
day job is a feature assignment for
Ridley Scott or your day job is you just
got staffed on Jane the Virgin and one
of my students justify I keep saying
it's got staff she's very excited you
have to do everything you have to that
you have to excel at that job but then
at night so we can you got to be writing
pitch perfect authentic scripts and
maybe you're not writing three or four a
year maybe you're writing two a year
because but you don't stop writing these
scripts and creating these scripts
because one of these scripts is going to
be the thing that takes your career to
the next level and so the writers that
don't get it is I'm working I'm making
money I've made it plus I'm busy it's
like I have a family I'm writing there's
no other time and I get that but the
reality is the writers that get it even
though they're working they're still
always creating these new material and
they think about it in six script cycles
and so a lot of times
agents drop the writers who aren't doing
that and you know I get it because like
when I was a working studio writer I
wasn't continue to write these scripts I
was just doing my studio assignment work
and I was making good money and I was
really I was too busy I didn't want to
do that
my agent kept telling me to do this I
didn't and he said at some point your
writing career is going to end badly and
I worked non-stop for 11 years but I was
a working writer but I never became an a
Lois writer and the only way I could
have become an a-list writer is to keep
writing the script so there was another
writer Erik singer who wrote a script
and he started getting all these studio
assignments and he was making a lot of
money but he kept writing on his own
time he's pitch perfect authentic script
year after year after year and
eventually one of them hit and it was
American hustle and so he's now suddenly
a huge writer I know the guys that wrote
the NIC same thing you know they're
their staff writers and they were making
really good money but they were writing
stuff that they really believed in and
the Nick was one of them and that's good
and that script just took them to a
whole other level Alan Ball with
American
you can go on and on and on so often
agents drop writers who might be really
great writers but they don't get it they
don't keep creating this new absolute so
it's either they don't keep creating
material or they're not creating the
right kind of mature it's not good
enough I have a lot of friends or agents
and if you keep creating the right kind
of content even when you're working in
the contents amazing and you play well
with others it's very unlikely they're
going to drop you because that's exactly
the kind of person they want to
represent and in that case if they drop
you it it could be a conflict of their
client play it could be a lot of things
have nothing to do with you but if
you're not doing all of those things and
an agent drops you then you have to look
in the mirror
I can go back to Sean Ryan again the one
who was so promising and he got a job on
a sitcom as soon as he came to LA and
then he didn't work for six years and
what he did is he wrote and I think that
he wrote about 14 spec scripts and what
happened is his scripts were all good
but nothing was getting him traction and
he asked his manager he said to his
manager send me an example of a script
that is getting somebody work and his
manager sent over the script that had
the most buzz at the time and Sean
compared it page to page and said he'd
have you know three things on a page
that were really good but this one the
one that got the buzz every single beat
was perfect and when he realized that he
had not been hitting the mark he started
to write and hit the mark and in not too
long of a time he got hired on a show
and that show led to another show and
then he got he developed the shield so
you just have to keep working
I wouldn't really call it early success
I it was I don't even view it that way I
view it as a six years of no one wanting
my stuff and it was you know some random
person who was very kind was interested
in a script but it wasn't as if it was
all of a sudden I made it and it's
happening now so it really was a six
seven year journey to selling my first
project which was recount and why I
didn't give up I think is because I had
something to say and I loved writing
these scripts and they were important to
me and I loved working on stories and it
just was artistically extremely
fulfilling where my acting career was
very frustrating and sometimes I and I
worked I didn't really seem worked on
some terrific shows that I'm really
proud of but I wasn't actually getting
to act very much so even when you're
working you know I would do episodes of
Gilmore Girls and I would do four
episodes of season and I would work on
it a day or two and that would be one of
my only jobs for six months so it's
really about seven days on set over a
six month period so what am i doing the
rest of the time I'm auditioning and
trying to get new jobs but that's an
hour a day maybe so really it was it was
a creative outlet for me of taking my
creative energy and putting it into
something where I can actually just go
do it
where as an actor you have to be picked
to go do it and then you rarely get
picked so I just found it fulfilling but
I also was getting rejected and left and
right script after script and agents
managers production company everyone
didn't want my work for six seven years
and I think I got to a point where I
asked myself well this is not going well
what are you what do you want from this
what what are you doing and I sort of I
asked myself would I and it's one of the
key questions in the movie would I do
this for the rest of my life if I got
nothing in return
and I thought yeah I would and then I
just kept writing and then eventually it
wasn't as if six months later cracked
the champagne it was
maybe three years later that I sold
recount as a pitch to HBO and then just
kind of went on from there but there was
a certain peace in knowing that it
wasn't about it wasn't about selling
something or success even though I
really wanted it I wasn't and what you
know wasn't a kumbaya moment but there
was a peace in knowing that well
whatever happens you just keep writing
so just keep writing and that's what I
did
when Jeffrey and I were starting we we
took a slightly academic view one day
and said what's your prediction about
the approach they're gonna take are they
gonna go more for story were they gonna
go more for character and we found out
the answer is neither they went for
conflict and so if you were to give us a
premise to develop the very first step
we would take is okay whatever the
premise is where do we get conflict out
of it okay if there are two characters
involved how can we make them butt heads
to do something because everything would
come out of that
writers
as one example I get query letters every
day line query letters
dear so-and-so it could be my name it
could be creative executive it could be
my name misspelled it could be anything
dear so-and-so log line short
description you know can I send you a
script I'll sign a release
sign John that's what I get repeatedly
all day long in my inbox there is not
one lick of research there is not one
look of anything personal like why is
this the writer the only writer who
could have written this story why was it
so compelling that they chose this out
of all the stories in one's imagination
why did they choose to send it to me now
I don't want to receive the agony the
ecstasy is a letter but something I drop
a kernel something that stands out and
makes them makes me think makes me react
makes me wonder about this but they
don't I can promise you not even 1% do
what I'm describing so this is what
writers learn from other writers it
could be actors learning from other
actors etc they learn the habitual
tried-and-true day-to-day protocol which
is usually very unsuccessful the ROI the
return on investment in sending blind
query letters has gotta be horribly
frustrating if you're a business you'd
be bankrupt so why do it you do it
because this is what other people are
doing you need to associate with with
more successful people and you need to
think about it differently if you were a
fashion designer and you took that
approach you focus on your craft focus
on your craft focus on your craft and
send out letters saying here's my
designs aren't I great you'd never have
a brand you have to think in terms of
business you have to think in terms of
what what more could I do that others
aren't doing as opposed to what they are
doing how do I stand out so separating
yourself out from the herd is definitely
the name of the game
and anyone who's invested all that blood
blood sweat and tears that sort of soul
equity investing all that time writing a
hundred and twenty or ten pages of
whatever of story and rewriting it till
it's just so that they want to share
their wares with the world now they're
so proud of this they should they should
invest a like amount of time in figuring
out how to market and how to be a
business person and how to reach out to
people how to do things differently than
all their peers like that's a great
measurement am i doing what everyone
else is doing or am I being somehow
putting myself out into the world and
speaking of myself to the right people
in ways that matter
a common notion particularly about
action heroes the notion was always in
the past that when you have an action
hero or especially a superhero that you
want a character who begins as a good
person upstanding moral paramount and
remains that way throughout the entire
story but about 10 years ago
Hollywood discovered that that's not the
best way to tell a superhero story
that's one of those examples of
conventional wisdom that's not so what
we care about is to see a character
overcome a deep weakness now the
audience thinks that this story is all
about the hero achieving his goal right
because then we've got success and
that's important and in most stories the
hero will accomplish his goal by the end
of the story but that is not what the
audience is most interested in they
can't tell you this but we know from
lots of experience hundreds of years of
storytelling that the cave the real fact
is not does the hero accomplish the goal
but does the hero overcome the great
weakness because that's what makes us
care about that character we see them in
pain we see them in trouble right if
they're already successful if they're
already a good and in some cases a
perfect person where do they go right
there's nothing for them to overcome so
that's why it's so important that we
show in the very opening pages of our
script the great internal weakness of
our character now we may also want to
give them qualities that are likable
qualities that the audience can also
hook on to but those are not nearly as
important as establishing the weakness
upfront in the story
I'll never forget when I was a studio
executives there was a certain
circumstance where this happened where
we had the network the studio and the
showrunners and the writer on the phone
and the writer was so defensive to the
network notes and it was my job to go to
the writer and say you need to really
hear the note understand the note and
then your pet best response that isn't
going to put somebody on the defense or
isolate someone is I'll take a look at
it okay that helps to first of all it
helps it's positive on the writer it's
saying that they're open it's not saying
they agree with it up but it's saying
they're open to take a look at it and
that's all people want to know what I
think the biggest thing writers have to
think about when it comes to receiving
notes on their script is even if they
don't agree with the note at face value
they have to understand there might be a
note under the note and the note they
need to make to themselves if something
isn't working and I have to figure out
how to make it work because if this
person who knows story is not getting it
then there's something going on in my
process that isn't working and just be
open to that I'm in the gift with
writing what I say to writers is you
have to recognize first of all the what
is the blank page is the only thing that
is between them and a writing career and
how they fill that page is what makes
the difference
so they can rewrite anything like that's
why I say the writers I cannot tell you
it was my job
how many showrunners I had to talk off
the ledge after they heard notes and
after they heard notes from the studio
or the owner of the company or the I had
to be the peacemaker and I had to really
help them to see alright at first I
think the writers mind may go oh my god
there's a total page one rewrite very
often it's not all it is is really
thinking about the note understanding
the note and then if they're open to it
what they what I've seen the best writer
for me knows how to make the note and go
beyond the note and that takes openness
you know that takes advanced ability to
really know all right well I'm gonna
make that note there and therefore
that's going to affect a later moment so
I'm going to change that later moment so
that it links with what I just changed
and they know how to do that I think
probably the biggest wall note is saying
you're wrong I don't agree I think that
is that shows lack of openness and
accessibility and desire to make the
story better so I I think you know when
writers will or they'll say I don't get
it and then the executive or or the
story consultant will go through it
again
and and I think like this is where I
think it comes to the person giving the
note there's also tremendous
responsibility I am definitely a
believer that if you're going to give a
note
give an example show them what you mean
so that they understand the note so I
mean there are many consultants who will
say I don't think that's my job I'm not
the writer they're the writer I am a
believer I come from the studio
executive perspective where clarity is
key in the outcome of the story so if
you're going to give a note and give an
example of why it's not working or what
you mean by it then you're going to have
a stronger chance of getting the outcome
that you want it's anything the thing
that most affected me was a script
doctor very good script doctor that I
had and and and there was a script I had
written when I was one of my favorite
scripts ultimately but what she said
this is brilliant I absolutely love it
now here's the notes and and but by the
fact that she said that I was brilliant
and that she loved it I thought well
what the heck with a few notes I'm
brilliant and I love it so I think you
know crazy flattery you know I really
sort of the weight of allowing somebody
to be feel special and be special with
crazy flattery that all those notes
seemed like nothing so you know one of
the biggest biggest pieces of advice was
that hey you know what you're doing has
super value now here's the work and just
going on that thing where I was allowed
to have super value at the top of the
journey really got me through I thought
it was nothing though it was nose
for character and I talked about this in
my Pixar seminar so because they masters
of this you know they tell stories about
toys about monsters about bugs about
robots right you know fish rat they make
you care and connect with those
characters so there's there's a whole
bunch of techniques and and you can see
what they do and you can know what the
techniques are for me it's like there's
three three things that you do that I
that you do is is make us make us feel
sorry for that character so there's a
little moments where you can you can
create a moment in the story where a
character is unjustly abused or unjustly
mistreated or insulted or betrayed or
neglected and so it could be any
character and if that moment is there
you're gonna feel sorry for that
character at that moment takes an
instant so that's one if you show that
they're like us if we show their
humanity for example your show that they
care about something other than
themselves that's another technique so
there's a moment in the movie Leon the
professional which is about a hitman
right and it opens with him doing a hit
and he kills people you don't know if
he's good or bad but he goes home and he
takes care of a plant right and that's
right away you say oh he cares about a
plant so he's okay he's human the other
part is admiration so this is like any
any kind of you know if you're dating
somebody or you're trying to find
somebody who's a good match for you
there's that list of lists of things
that you like in a person that's an
admirable trait so somebody was funny
who's responsible who's courageous it's
a whole list of things you can add to a
character to make us say oh well you
know I admire this usually they're like
the best at what they do they're like
the best you know the best at executive
or the best agent the best cop the best
driver their courageous
there's a whole bunch of em I mean have
a hope the list the list is all in the
book there's all these lists of things
you can do but if you do these three
things and I saw when I show clips of
the of the moment you meet the character
and usually like a three-minute scene
you can see all these things being
applied in like three minutes there's
like you know the the opening of wall-e
after he's done with the garbage he
comes to us to his little house it's a
three minute scene and it's about 20 of
these techniques done this is how you
connect with that character in one scene
emotionally I also show a clip of a of
an ad the commercial it's a one minute
thing about a lamp whether it's it's a
great ad for IKEA award-winning
commercial where they make you carry
mostly for the lamp right and and the
the joke about is that the guy comes I
says you know you probably had feelings
for these lamps that bit that's because
you're crazy the lamp has it's only a
lamp it's you know and the new one is
better you know the new lamp to replace
it so but anyway but it's great it's
amazing once you once you know those
techniques and then you see him in
action you got my conned you know and
now and I kind of always feel I was give
this caveat with to my students and to
anybody who hears me speak that if you
love stories if you love films and you
don't want me to destroy the illusion do
not listen to me because I feel like I'm
one of the magicians who would give you
the trick of how it's done and you then
you see the trick and it's not the same
anymore so I always feel bad about that
because you know once you know the
techniques and you see a film you're
gonna see him everywhere all the time
and it's gonna kind of ruin it for you
so just fair warning right there that
you know those are those are this is how
we do it and that creates that effect
you know
it's not an audience's or a readers job
to feel something that's something you
have to elicit so it means you haven't
created sufficient conflict in your
story to elicit emotion or you haven't
created a premise a concept of a story
you haven't structured in such a way
that that conflict makes any sense or it
can be mostly involving because you've
given the reader nothing to root for or
you haven't created empathy with the
hero or whatever it might be but it's
your job to elicit emotion the emotion
has to come naturally from the reader an
audience because of what they're what
you've done they have to be
participating in the story you've
created that's why for example empathy
is so important for the hero for you to
create for your hero because a story is
a participatory experience for the
audience of a listener of the reader we
become that character we want to
experience the emotion as they do it's
not we don't go to the movies because
it's interesting to watch people do
things it's emotional for us to get to
do them we become Jason Bourne we become
rose as she falls in love with Jack and
is on the Titanic we become the woman
who the astronaut who's out in space and
gravity we are a part of it we're
participating in the action in the
events of that story but we have no
basis no way to get into the story
if we don't on a subconscious level
become the hero of that story and that's
what the empathy and identification you
create at the beginning is going to do
so if you've created a story with an
empathetic heroes that we participate
giving them a clear goal and created
enough logical believable obstacles to
overcome then the emotion will grow
organically out of your audience because
they're in it and you've created the
conflict that will do that to me all
roads lead to the outer motivation and
so if all you're doing is stringing
together obstacles to overcome and
there's a very similar mistake and that
is people who think comedy is one funny
thing after
happening that's not what that's not
what a story is a story is the sequence
of events experienced by a hero who's
pursuing a very specific goal so if
you're just throwing one obstacle after
another but we don't care about the hero
or the hero it's not clear why the hero
is doing this or what they're trying to
achieve or if those obstacles are
illogical or if the pace of the story
lags or if everything is at a very high
level of emotion and you're not creating
sort of peaks and valleys to the
emotional level so you have big moments
in quiet moments and moments of
connection and moments of separation and
so on there are all those things you've
got to do in addition to throwing a
bunch of you know car chases and fight
scenes up on the screen which many
people have tried and those movies don't
succeed if if it's just car chases and
fight scenes it's just you know it's
just a series of videos really but it's
not a story or a movie that are people
are going to be involved in well it has
to alternate yeah it's it's not a
resting point as if you stay there
forever but you don't it's like in a
comedy you don't want joke joke joke
joke joke there's got to be a serious
moment or two and and look at any great
comedy look at or even any decent comedy
and there's going to be something very
funny but there's going to be something
touching or sad or romantic or there's
going to be a deeper connection between
the characters or there's going to be
something more exciting or there's going
to be something softer you want to vary
the peaks and valleys the emotional
level and and pitch of the story as we
go steadily toward the finish line that
the hero is trying to reach so the
obstacles need to get bigger they need
to come closer together as it moves
forward so the pace will accelerate but
if there's only obstacles one right
after the other with no chance to catch
our breath no chance to anticipate what
might be coming no chance to explain
what's going on and no chance to get
closer or deeper into the characters
it's going to be a very very shallow
story with very limb
emotional involvement or appeal
my process evolves every time I do
another job I realized how much I didn't
know and my prior job so it's it's I'm
somebody who reads pretty much every
trick every screenwriting book every
script that I could get my hands on and
I'm constantly trying to evolve as a
craftsman
I also unfortunate enough in this job to
surround myself with really talented
people and you learn a lot from other
writers like there were writers on won
Emmys or you know Martin Scorsese's best
friend is another one like you you want
to really kind of learn from from the
people around you and that just makes
you better so I can't say that I have
any set process although right now as
I'm developing something I have to say
I'm a big fan of the John Truby John
truly stuff I think he kind of hits a
sweet spot for me but you know I've
taken them all taking the key taking
everyone I'm one of these guys who likes
to learn new stuff about the craft and I
figure if I can learn something from any
book if I get one thing out of it
just being able to recognize your
deficiencies and for me you know when I
read a great script and I go oh my gosh
you know this is a great script I get
really excited about it what are they
doing that I'm not doing like what can I
learn from what this writer did and so I
think just constantly learning
you know I'm constantly reading and
constantly researching and having that
in the back of your mind all the time
that you want to get better you'll just
gravitate towards things that make you
better instead of finding that
comfortable place where you know you
know you're good at writing this so I'm
just gonna write this over and over I
think forcing yourself to stretch and
because once you do that again it's it's
a great feeling you know when you've
written something good and you've done
something you haven't done before you
then you have something that you feel
really proud of you can learn from
and that's the thing there's so many
people who I think people just want to
feel validated so badly that they get to
a place where they're like I'm the
expert and everyone's just been
listening to what I have to say about
this and that's it's kind of crazy
because yeah you may have put your ten
thousand hours and you may be very good
at what you do but you can learn
something from everything that you read
even learning what not to do but even in
in really bad scripts you'll find these
little moments where I'm like oh my gosh
that was really well conveyed or you
know so just being open to those things
and learning from other people because
people are constantly adding to this
body of work that exists in the world
and there's so much for you to be able
to read out there just you know be open
to what other people are doing I but
then again you have to love reading so
many writers don't love reading so you
know read read read read and see what
other people are doing a lot of people
want to start writing without ever
having read a script and I just I don't
understand it probably the most
important perspective has been to see it
as something I'm always learning and I'm
always growing and that's okay it's not
like I'm supposed to know it all and be
perfect at it and the things that I
write are gonna just be great
automatically and others are gonna love
them to see it more as it's an ongoing
quest of kind of a self development self
education I'm learning with everything
that I write what works better and and
and not as good so that it's like it's
like this this journey of development
that you sort of like are gonna enjoy
the journey as opposed to I have to get
to a certain place which it's easy to
feel that way because the world works
that way where I have to get the agent I
have to get the sale I have to get
something produced I have to raise the
money and make my movie like there's all
these goals we might have in the world
and a lot of times they're out of our
control and if you focus only on those
goals like what I can get what I can
achieve instead of what can i express
how can I just do what I decide I want
to do which is be a writer and be
learning and growing and find some
satisfaction in that journey because
when you turn it into there have to be
these quantifiable results in terms of
money
or others reactions or whatever then
you're putting all your power in this
thing that may or may not ever happen
that you can't for sure make happen no
matter what you do so I think that
attitude
it might seem counterproductive because
it's like well to be successful you want
to you know professional you want to
focus on the professional goals right
well you you do to some extent and you
are open to feedback and you are listen
you know you are educating yourself I
didn't say just go in a hole and just do
what you want to do and never and shut
the outside world out I'm saying engage
with the world with feedback with
education with trying to understand and
get better so it's growth but making it
a positive growth for yourself that is
about making me better and making my
writing better not making my results
better because when you focus on how do
I give more how do I write something
that's really going to impact people
more how do I do that how do I figure
out how to do it how do I get better at
it
you're then about giving to other people
and you will achieve success I believe
more when you succeed at giving more you
will get more automatically as opposed
to how do I get the success how do I get
the breaks how do I get the right person
to read it how do I get people to like
it it's more how do I create something
so wonderful that people will just
automatically like it I'm not even
concerning myself with that so it's like
taking the power into your own hands and
being about how you can improve your
stuff and yourself as a writer having
that approach I think is a is a stronger
healthier approach that's gonna lead to
success more than if you do it the other
way
of the number one reason why you are not
making it is the material is not yet
good enough because you if you're not
especially if you're not reading you
know that reading the stuff that's out
there you have no way of knowing how
good good has to be in order to get
noticed and coming in you have to be
better than most of the people who are
now making a living at it in order to
get noticed even but the contests offer
you know the boss talk about Ryabkov a
concrete way to do that work on it and
work on it and work on it until you've
got something you're ready to test but
now pick your contests carefully the
first time you try it out pick smaller
contests you know more more fringing I
mean do your research they should be
decent upstanding contests and so forth
try it out try it out did you make the
quarterfinals or were you swept away you
know in in the first pass through okay
if that happens you have learned
something it's not ready and you keep
working on it and you keep working on it
and finally when you know you get to the
mid-level ranks and let's say it gets
your your script gets to the
quarterfinals okay but it did not make
the top 10 or top 15 fine you've learned
something more go back take a vacation
for a couple of weeks try not to think
about it then read it again make more
notes and go back to work on it and it
is a way to that's the thing see what
what what a lot of neophyte
screenwriters new screenwriters don't do
or don't pursue which is you have got to
be as a writer as a craftsperson
you must be relentless in your goal of
creating quality
for instance I'll give you for instance
and maybe that was sort of I'm working
with a young lady right now who was one
of our grad students a few years a
couple two three years ago she's been my
assistant class assistant and stuff like
that so we know each other pretty well
she took her thesis screenplay from I
don't know three years ago and I read it
and I told her you got a great idea here
you know you really do I believe in this
idea and we had conversations about you
know there's no such thing as a bad
screenplay only an unfinished one and
all that and I gave her some pointers
and you know scribbled things on the
pages and she went back and she wrote it
again this is a feature film and I
looked at it you know this is better
this is a little better and I went
through at the end you know the sample
editing and scribble-scribble and all
this kind of stuff and then she takes it
and she comes back and it's a little bit
better she has been through that process
well in this case with me oh it must be
six times now I mean years have passed I
mean that was she this she she had a
draft of this when she went up for her
thesis three years ago right but I'll
tell ya and I'm reading it once again
I'll probably be looking at it again
this weekend she is so close it's so
close what I would really like to I kept
telling her keep track of don't lose
your draft of your of your first draft
don't lose a copy of your first draft
because a day is coming I would like to
have that in my hand and your final
draft and put that together in a binder
and use this in class have people read
the first draft now read the last draft
and that I believe could be a wonderful
wonderful exploration of teaching and
screenwriting because this has become
viable she is now close to having a an
entirely shootable
casting really good social commentary
screenplay what changed in those six
drafts over the three years
craft craft her mastery of I mean what
most of them do is they write what they
mean when they come to dialog people
just blurt it out and it's called
on-the-nose dialogue that's one of the
things you teach stop it people do not
talk like that people talk around what
they mean not that there can't be
confrontation and stuff like that under
certain emotional circumstances yes but
it was dialogue and less is more in
terms of the amount of dialogue in
description it was about the use of
language and vocabulary in description
using irrelevant words the and there
there's a whole list of there's the nine
most utterly useless words I got it back
there on a sheet I pass out sometimes
all that is is filler all that does is
slow the reader down it is developing a
style in the way you describe and and
offer exposition and description in in
scene with seen heading slug lines and
then what we're looking at and stuff
like that drawing people in where you
put things the plot building the plot in
an ever better way you can do more here
you could do more here that's what's
been going on for all those years
most overrated part of the screenplay
equation is the idea ideas are really
pretty useless and worthless again
forgive me if repeating myself but I am
a one of those people who believes that
Breaking Bad is one of the greatest
achievements in the history of
civilization I think it's really great
great drama so what's the idea that
drives it a high school chemistry
teacher gets a cancer diagnosis and so
he decides to go into the
methamphetamine trade with an
incorrigible former student of his a
criminal you know to sell drugs to
support his family there's a stupidest
idea I've ever heard many many companies
shot that down and yet it is this
triumphant achievement 62 hours of a TV
series every frame of which is engaging
and and captivating and involving and
the so how did that happen the answer is
they told a good story it's where the
story it's really all about story that's
what we believe
at UCLA that's that's what I believe a
few years I mean imagine if somebody
came up to you and and said I have an
idea for a movie
this guy's stutters but he has to give a
speech so he hires a speech therapist
they work on the speech he gives a
speech at the end of the movie if
somebody told you that that's gonna win
the Oscar for Best Picture and Best
Screenplay you figure they're crazy and
yet that is of course the King's Speech
and again I think it just demonstrates
the the value of story and the value
lessness of ideas and I think that the
very young people are more into ideas
they have great ideas I like to say when
you have a great idea if you have a
really really great idea for a
screenplay that's all you've got I think
what remains after that everything the
characters have to be invented the
dialogue they speak
has to be created it has to be punchy
and peppy and provocative and pungent
I'm just getting into peas now and
poetic and it has to be worth listening
to or for itself just because there's
something kind of charming about it but
beyond that it can't be just for itself
it also has to advance the story in a
palpable measurable identifiable way
likewise expand the audience's
appreciation of the characters it takes
time for me to give you an idea about a
movie I can you know takes a handful of
seconds to walk you through the story of
the movie who takes to the length of the
movie a couple of hours so that's where
the value is
there is a huge business maybe an overly
huge business in teaching screenplay
structure a three-act structure of five
extra you know and and and there are
there are I know I know a fair share of
screenwriting gurus who are at each
other's throats all the time about which
structure is the structure and I'm not
saying there's not a structure I would
be in big trouble if I said there wasn't
a structure and that a story didn't have
a beginning a middle and an end
but this reliance the the the the the
this absolute like like need to follow
any structure map that's out there and
if your and if you don't have a turning
point on page thirty you haven't done it
right or if you're on step five of
twenty two steps and you're on the wrong
step you haven't done it right or any of
this stuff it's not true this structure
business it's a business and I can't guy
and you need a diagram to teach
structure and and and you sell a diagram
and it's very it's it's very hard to say
I have the best diagram unless you have
a diagram right I mean you need a
diagram to sell a diagram I told you
earlier about my diagram that ends on
page sixty with someone hanging
themselves
it's an emotional diagram it goes like
this it's like page one oh god I can do
this this is gonna be great this is best
story over page ten oh my god I can
really do this everyone was wrong about
me my parents can go F themselves I'm a
writer on and on motional and then like
about page 20 you go oh god this is
really getting hard and it sorts than
the graph starts going down and down and
then again you get to page 60 and like
I'll never finish this you hang yourself
it's my structure okay it's an emotional
structure
it's an emotional diagram but wait sorry
to interrupt but what happens after the
hanging man oh well you you go into
despair for a while you put yourself to
bed then you wake up and you start again
and it has a happy ending and at the
ending there's big bags of money all the
sex you ever wanted power that you know
you win right but it's it's it's
obviously tongue-in-cheek and add to
make a point but but but the real point
of it is is that have characters who you
believe in and you believe that you can
write them and that they are in some
sense writing you that they're coming
out of a place of truth for you put them
in the tightest the most impossible
situation you can imagine and get them
out of it and know that you have
probably need to do it if you're writing
a screenplay in a hundred to a hundred
and twenty minutes and let the story
flow and there will be natural points
within you doing that where you will
feel that the story needs to go faster
needs to go slower that that that there
needs to be more drama there needs to be
a moment of rest all of these things
that structure teaches you and again I'm
not saying there isn't a structure but
those structure diagrams they can be an
annus assist you or they can be a cage
hmm they can be an absolute cage and
they can trap you and there is if you
believe that you that you're a writer
you have a natural storytelling gift
that you need to honor that you need
your respect er don't be a writer
I mean don't don't think that you can
tell a story if you don't feel that you
have a natural storytelling gift and you
can't tell when things are going too
slowly or things are going too fast and
just let it flow and then go back and
see if it's structured right but this is
another thing that will stop people dead
in their tracks over and over again is
your first act is too long who cares who
cares you'll figure that out if writing
is rewriting in the rewrite and and and
watch a lot of movies read a lot of
books I am now because of constraints of
time some time I'm a podcast junkie I
hear the most brilliant stories in
podcasts and stories that have a natural
beginning a middle and an end because
they're true just embrace all of that
embrace the movies that you love take
them to your heart and if you're a
storyteller the story will emerge and it
will merge with a structure
the biggest lesson about writing is get
up and do it you know is like it is a
job you know I I'm the kind of guy that
I like a glass of wine you know I like
some music going that's very romantic
and I'm sure Hemingway would be very
proud but like that's really not how you
get a script done or how you write that
many scripts and I I am always driving
so it's like you gotta get up you got to
spend time with your coffee you got to
look at it and sometimes it's just
sitting there
not being able to write anything that
gets you two days later to where you are
where you can you know answer the
question and put it on paper everybody
says you have to write and read every
day because it's true if you're if
you're writing every day you know the
next day you're gonna you're gonna write
a little better than you did the day
before and in four years you're gonna be
a much better writer than you were four
years ago and I think a lot of writers
you're waiting to for the world to give
you permission to pursue your craft and
you just need it you need to give
yourself that permission you need to
show up and say okay I'm gonna do this
and I might not be very good right now
or you know maybe I am great and I don't
know it yet you won't know either way
unless you put yourself out there and
sitting down every day whether that's
you know for an hour in the morning an
hour in the evening somewhere in between
the timing doesn't matter and it really
doesn't even matter you know if you're
writing a thousand words or if you're
writing fifty the important thing is
that you're writing